[Musique]
les enfants bonsoir soit roudeina
mais vous êtes très nombreux ce soir que
deux au costume de belles robes et que
de masse je ne vous reconnais plus mais
oui vous l'avez reconnu ces gros ours
est lui aussi s'est déguisé en danseuse
de tahiti oui en danseuse de tahiti et
mirabel et petit louis comment se
sont-ils déguisés qui l'oublient en
indien au mieux rappel en gîte and roll
je vais vite les admirer encore au repos
[Musique]
[Rires]
vivre à des gens aux non non tu trouves
pas eu l'air d'une fille comme ça on les
appelle des gîtes ans et ils portent des
chapeaux noirs comme sa colère et
maintenant la fête commence voilà des
serpentins et de confettis course aux
places pour le final couple et depuis
aucun nom
[Musique]
gta iv
cegetel à tahiti j'ai pas pu y aller on
veut non c'est vrai les enfants voilà
patron j'arrive à l'est pour livraison
en coop des grands tout seul
allez jo sagement le veut le renault son
port en eau profonde en portant par un
taillis tahiti pompon propos pour lido
mirabel
[Musique]
voilà un petit mur des farc
vous voyez petit louis et mirabel sont
déjà couchés et vous aussi les petits
enfants faites comme eux enlevez
sagement vos beaux costumes et aller
vite au dodo voilà notre danseuses
tahitiennes moi tu sais gros source
tu n'as pas l'air très sérieux bonne
nuit petit louis bonnet mirabel une
bonne nuit les petits enfants à demain à
demba
m
[Musique]